6
23 on your wednesday morning hey we're
checking in on the status
of those hov lanes well the bottom line
for now
is that hov lanes can only legally be
driven if there are two or more people
in a vehicle
any time of the day or night there are a
couple of exceptions motorcycles rtc
buses and emergency vehicles well the
nevada department of transportation says
it
may take a look at modifying the 24 7
status of those lanes but
don't expect anything to change anytime
soon ndot's tony ilya tells me
we are tentatively looking to commission
an 18-month study
to determine the high peak use hours of
hov lanes in clark county
he says the results could provide
guidance toward future hov
operational decisions but even that
study's not a done deal tony adds a
contract won't come before the state
transportation board until may
or possibly june so the bottom line not
much changing right now we'll keep you
posted buckle up drive carefully please
put down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com